to be fair election day for the most
part went pretty smoothly in los angeles
and a lot of big cities
businesses bordered up their stores in
anticipation of possible protests
and looting stores like pottery barn
and tiffany in beverly hills
but you know what i was surprised to see
how many smaller businesses assumed
people
would want to steal from their stores a
lot of these places
i don't think needed to worry for
example
this pet food store tales and scales
probably did not need to board up the
bassoon
center in detroit probably overestimated
its popularity
honeys honey and hummels north america's
only honey and hummel store
i think they were just well they were
being cocky to board up
the owner of reno nevada's s.a.t
workbook store
probably just being paranoid the
laserdisc and vhs emporium in phoenix
arizona
yeah probably unnecessary caution
why would a1 attack dogs training center
think anyone was going to break in
look at this one this store selling
merch for the 90s hit sitcom
coach starring craig t nelson boarded up
no not necessary the iphone case
bedazzler at the glendale galleria come
on
and finally even on hollywood boulevard
the people dressed as elmo's thought
they would be
looted yeah people went overboard